on the prowl only a week after being
freed from prison but Jordan McSweeney
had already broken the rules of his
release and should have been back in
jail probation service blunders left him
free to roam the streets looking for a
victim
he chose law graduate Zara Alina in a
terrifying and ruthless attack McSweeney
sexually assaulted her then kicked her
to death
the probation service should have
assessed Jordan McSweeney as being a
high risk of serious harm to the public
had they done so the way that his
release from prison was planned and the
controls that were put around him would
have been far tougher and more robust
and there would have been more
opportunities to bring him back to
prison within days of his release
McSweeney had missed probation meetings
he was recalled to prison but not
quickly enough the paperwork was delayed
then police couldn't find him according
to the report mcsweeney's previous
convictions his recent crimes and his
violence in prison were all viewed in
isolation nobody joined the dots if they
had they would have realized he was at
high risk of reoffending
police finally did catch up with
McSweeney the day after he murdered Zara
last week it emerged that Damien Bendel
was another violent criminal poorly
managed by the probation service he went
on to kill three children and his
pregnant partner
in a statement prisons and probation
Minister Damien Hines said we are taking
immediate steps to address the serious
issues raised by the Jordan McSweeney
and Damian Bendel cases this includes
mandatory training to improve risk
assessments implementing new processes
to guarantee the Swift recall of
offenders and we have taken disciplinary
action where appropriate
the probation officers Union blamed the
failings on earlier privatization of
their service and current staff
shortages it urged that Justice
secretary to boost investment
Martin brunt Sky News